اقدم الجنود الاوكرانيين ليست على ارض
صلبه تحصينات وخنادق تغمرها المياه والوحل
ليضاف الى اختبار الصقيع اختبار قوه
التحمل
لكن الامر اصعب قليلا بسبب المطر والصقيع
انه مستنقع يمكنك رؤيته بنفسك لقد جفت
قليلا اليوم لكن لا باس نحن صامدون
مياه ووحل داخل خنادق الجنود الاوكرانيين
لكن الاحتماء بها امر لا تراجع عنه حتى ان
غابت الامكانات تبقى ملاذا موحلا لكن امنا
من الصواريخ الروسيه
فقد جفت لكن مستوى المياه كان بهذا
الارتفاع كان مستنقعا بسبب المطار
استخدمنا دلائل لازاله المياه
تحديات اختبار فصل الشتاء بين اوكرانيا
وروسيا قد يطول امادها
[موسيقى]
اما فوهه المدافع فلا تهدا لعل اصواتها
تصبح دافعا للاستمرار والبقاء على قيد
الحياه لمن هم اسفل خنادق الحرب
علي السمان العربيه